All right, welcome to another Zoom call is the end of August and we're at our I think our sixth year reunion and doing the Zoom calls maybe seven years. I can't even remember anymore. It's been at least six years.
I know we started in August six or seven years and we'll do this a lot of Zoom calls.
Recorded that you can listen to.
If you have no life, so we don't much time it. Go live your life, don't be listening to all these.
All right, so let's get started. Remember if you have questions in between Zoom calls go to our website and look at our blog and make sure everybody that's on the Zoom calls definitely better than the membership site now.
So I can take the announcement out from now on.
Okay, questions sent in number one is it safe to check the right machine and laptop in its case as luggage at the airport or does it need to be.
Take it as a carry on no, I think it's safe. I mean, I have checked. I have never put it in its case.
So when I traveled with it, I've only brought the right in the laptop in the ball, but I wrapped it in the sweatshirt and put it in my carry on or put it in my checked luggage.
So I never brought the case.
I'm sure it's just fine to me. My thought is that that little case, if I check it, that's something that could be easily get lost, I guess. I don't know.
But I know people have checked the case. I know people have, I've certainly checked the right, put wrapped in stuff in my suitcase and I've certainly brought it as a carry on.
I've done both. So it's perfectly safe. I would think it's probably safer in the case because, you know, you got, you know, those cases are, you know, all the foam.
I think you can throw it out of the airplane and still be protected. Those are pretty strong cases. So, I think you're fine, traveling with it. I don't think anybody's had troubles with that.
I have a relative whose pediatrician is saying no one can be around her soon to be born. Maybe, unless they have a who big cough vaccine. That's very interesting.
The last time I had a detailed shot was 2010, although I had a tennis in 2019. Now I have staged for a very cancer. I don't know that I should be getting any vaccines, even though I haven't done any chemo at this point. What is your opinion?
Well, I can't give you my opinion on medications from a legal standpoint, but personally, I'm not getting any vaccines. I know a lot of people maybe on this call have got the COVID vaccine. And I'm not here to judge anybody, but I think you need to do some investigation on vaccines.
I think anybody that's getting any vaccines or vaccinating their children at this point in time with all the information that's out there on the dangers of these microgulses of aluminum mercury are not reading the literature.
That's all I can say. There's just no way I would want to jail before I would get a vaccine at this point. So that's just my opinion. You can throw it in the garbage can if you want.
But today I went to my family doctor that concert is for my weight loss. I am down to 157 pounds.
So I went to 230 before the cancer was diagnosed and lost about 20 pounds since I went to the doctor in May. Okay, that's very concerned. So May, you went mid May, mid June, mid July, mid August or three months losing 20 pounds. That's not technically Cakesia at this point. Cakesia is losing two to four pounds a week.
I mean, you're not quite at that. But the question is, can any of the supplements be taken away or can there be any adjustments. So I am not so full feeling throughout the day.
Do they have to be taken every day. So, whatever we've talked about this multiple times about pulsing your supplements. There's nothing wrong with doing some pulsing.
You're having some issues like this where, you know, you're, you know, you're having to drink so much water to swallow supplements because you're not good at swallowing supplements.
Can you pulse them? If you're not good at swallowing supplements and you put two pills in your mouth and you have to drink half a glass of water to stop swallowing.
You have to think about doing something different like opening up the capsules and putting it in a, you know, a very small six ounce smoothie, you know, it'd be good to maybe put some protein powder in a smoothie so you can, and some other like complex carbs in the smoothie.
So it's actually a high calorie drink or a higher calorie drink. And then you're getting your nutrition in that or opening up the capsules and sprinkling it on your oatmeal in the morning or something like that, you got to think of things like that.
Yes, oh, I drank so much water taking my supplements. I can't even eat, can't even eat my food. You got to think of adding, open up the capsules and adding it to your food, something like that.
If you're having trouble putting on weight, you have to add some complex carbs back to your diet.
Remember I said last week there's some studies that have come on on regular potatoes. We've always said no white potatoes, which we read potatoes purple potatoes.
Anything that is a true potato is falls into that category because they have such a high glycemic index.
But now they're coming up with some studies. If you bake them twice, you drop the glycemic index, but you still have the benefit of the complex carbohydrate for weight gain.
So you bake six potatoes on Sunday and then on Monday, you you put them in the fridge after you're done baking them for an hour and 20 minutes or whatever you're doing.
And then on Monday, you take out a potato from the fridge and you bake it again for 20 minutes to get it nice and hot inside and you eat a nice steam baked potato with some fat on it like an oil like an olive oil on it or coconut oil on it or some
or some butter on it, if you're not out of there and free diet.
And you can put some other some vegetables on it, some broccoli or something like that. It can be a really nice meal that can give you some complex carbohydrates that could help you gain some weight.
So when you try to gain weight, you have to add complex carbohydrates back to your diet like oatmeal like rice like twice baked potatoes, like I just said, things like that.
Can I do a castor oil pack while I'm in my infrared sauna, just try to kill two birds with one stone, try to save some time.
For sure, I don't see any problem with the way to castor oil pack while in your infrared sauna, if you can figure out the logistics of that, I don't see any issue with that.
Like I just started a protocol a couple of weeks ago and he has been so thirsty, is this a part of the detoxification.
Well, maybe possibly so if he has changed his diet drastically, then definitely blood sugar issues could cause an increase in thirst.
So there's other factors that can be a part of this.
We don't want to just blame it on his detoxie. That's why he's thirsty. So if a good idea to get his glucose levels change is checked.
He would go over a one C checked, good idea to get a CBC or complete metabolic panel just to see to make sure that his electrolytes are in balance and things like that.
So get to your functional medicine doctor or your colleges to get just to get some standard blood.
Is it really should not have anything to do with supplements.
I started all your recommendations supplements yesterday. I enjoyed the green drink. It had flavor.
I really like the green drink to myself, especially when you've had some frozen berries and things to it. It's very I think it's very tasty.
Can I eat organic carbohydrates like a Z-Keele bread?
Yes.
No.
So first of all, let me put a little caveat in this person. I don't have their file in front of me.
So I don't know what they can. I can't eat.
So really the rest of this question.
Can I eat carbohydrates, carry go butter, tomatoes, kiwi, bison, wild grown puff mushrooms from our neighbors yard.
Yes, the size. Well, yes, anybody can eat those.
A cup of daily coffee. Yeah, pretty much anybody can have that wild caught fish. Depends on your diet that we have you on.
Save with the bison kiwi. Yes, you can eat that tomatoes. Yes, you can eat that carry go butter.
Depends on if we took you off of dairy.
So wait until you get on your, if you haven't jumped on the Zoom call for the binder review.
So I think those are a one day on Tuesdays. So if you haven't done that next Tuesday, you'll do your binder review.
Yes, I think they're on Tuesdays.
Look at the member site when those are so that is these are really questions for your binder review and, and we'll go over that in detail with you.
But you can look at your binder if you're supposed to be off of a dairy, then you really shouldn't be eating, you know, too much carry go butter.
Yeah, understand. When we take you off of something, it doesn't mean you have to be off of it, like completely, ever, ever touch that thing again, it's within reason.
Can you eat some ham at Easter Christmas. Yes, could you have some a little bit of butter.
Every few days and I don't see any major problem with that. So when I was in the throws of my cancer, I was supposed to be off of dairy.
I used a dairy substitute for everything, but there was times that I cheated and had a little butter carry go butter again as my favorite to.
Second part of this question at the bottom, I'm starting the right machine tonight. Can I wear any in the life patches.
Yes, the last piece is I like Cheetos.
I love people like this. So honesty is the best way to deal with things, right. I like Cheetos to actually have to take it back. I actually haven't tasted Cheetos for one 25 years, but I gotta tell you a little secret.
Like Cheetos, you should look at a product called paleo puffs, paleo puffs, paleo, it doesn't have any dairy whatsoever, but they have a no cheese paleo puff that has a organic cheese like powder, they're really good.
So yes, they might not be as flavorful as Cheetos because Cheetos filled with MSG and a whole bunch of garbage that you wouldn't want to feed your dog, but it is once you get used to the paleo puffs, you're going to really like those if you like Cheetos.
And the chat referring back to a question back here, I have stomach cancer, clarify that I can have white potatoes, remember I said twice baked. So if you're baking them, cooking them all the way through baking them, put them in the fridge and then baking them again.
Twice baked potatoes is going to decrease the glycemic index, that means it breaks down to glucose much slower.
And then you get the benefit of the carbohydrate, but you don't get the negative of the spike in glucose.
I have experienced experiencing severe back pain and bill does not help, do you have anything that I can take for paid.
No, not really. So from a natural perspective, it's, it's very difficult to compete for pain relief with drugs.
You just don't get the same benefit. So the first step you do for a natural perspective with mild pain is take typically anti inflammatory white willow bark can be used that is where they initially got salicylic acid from, but certainly it's not going to work the same as even taking aspirin.
But that can be used to help with pain, but it's only going to work with pretty mild pain, high dose anti inflammatory like curcumin, Boswellia, and DGCG from green tea extract, resveratrol, sting dental, corsetin, those are different flavonoids that can help with pain.
But if you have very severe pain, it's really not going to touch it. If Advil isn't really healthy, no, Advil is more of an anti inflammatory, some people don't do well with Advil, they don't metabolize it personally, I can't take Advil, I get sick and love it, if I take Advil, I'm afraid of what would happen to me if I took it now.
So you might have to try some other over the counter, and otherwise make sure you talk to your oncologist and see if you could get something stronger.
If you know long standing pain can really drag, you know, you drag it out in a lot of different ways and you don't necessarily want to go down that pathway.
So using a medication sometimes is wise to block that pain pathway. It doesn't mean that you necessarily have to be out of medication on a constant, you know, basis, it's just sometimes just blocking that pathway can just break that pain cycle.
So try some different things over the counter talk to your medical doctor that could possibly prescribe something as well.
The only other thing that from a natural perspective that people have used for paid is marijuana.
Now, I don't know what state this person is in what the legalities are for that state, but if you are at a state where it's legal and you feel comfortable with it, we do, we have had patients that have used marijuana, either smoking it or using a gummy or some sort of chewable or dropper that has helped with paid.
That is another that's really that's probably the strongest natural pain relief is from marijuana.
So think about that if that is available in your state.
What are your thoughts on electric reclining chairs, lazy boy chairs, I'm shopping for a recliner and while I know the electrical components run through the chair, the ease of use when you're you are feeling well is appealing.
And there are many more functions, however, I don't want to cause more harm than good.
Do you think there's an EMF concerned with the hydro harmonizer on the chair, be it after protecting me.
Honestly, I don't think there's probably any EMF concerned with the electric chairs, the motors, you know, aren't running constantly, they're only running when you use the chair itself.
It's simply a hydraulic lift.
I personally have electric reclining chair, find it very comfortable and easy to use.
I have never tested the EMFs with my EMF meter simply because there's just no way it's putting out EMFs, I don't see any issues with them.
I think they're great, they've really improved them.
I have been running a fever almost every day, typically around 100 degrees for a few weeks.
I have, I did have an infection at the tumor site that caused a hundred and two plus fever, but I believe that I have cleared that infection.
Does the black sand process sometimes induce a fever?
Maybe because of the immune response.
Yes, that could be possible, anything is possible.
What you want to do with this is talk to your local GP about just running a complete blood count, a CBC, and see if you have elevated white blood cells, because if you do have an infection, you will have elevated white blood cells.
That's just an increase in temperature because your body is creating an increased immune response, you typically not have an increased white blood cell count.
So that would be the thing that would be good to, that I would run.
Just admitting people here jumping on.
So, but yes, I mean, when a person has a fever for a long period of time, there are some concerns you don't want to have a long standing infection.
That you're not dealing with because that can drag your body down in different ways.
And typically just inflammation, like chronic inflammation is not going to cause a fever.
So now I have said over and over again that a fever isn't a bad thing. A fever is a good thing.
It's that is what can cause the body to knock a cancer into remission actually.
I told you stories of people that we've had in the past that got really sick with the flu cancer patient and actually having the flu and being really sick and having that high fever actually sent their cancer into remission because they had such a spike in their immune system that that we should go on and purposely be exposed to diseases, but that is a phenomena that has been documented before.
So that is the whole purpose of at least toxins that were given in years past as well and new research that is done.
I saw an episode of our local new station, I think it was Mayo or Cleveland clinic that were doing studies about giving biotoxin mixes to patients in a novel approach that would cause a fever state and cause a person to go into remission with cancer, of course, never went beyond the initial study because they can't make any money off of it unfortunately.
Next question, I had a doctor appointment today to check baby since I am currently pregnant and newly diagnosed with breast cancer. They asked if I was taking a prenatal vitamin, I stated I am taking some supplements, but how do I explain who recommended them without mentioning your clinic, you can mention our clinic and you should certainly disclose what supplements you're taking to your doctor.
I've said in videos in the past that patients have sometimes when they go to their oncologist, have it fully disclosed everything that they're taking to their oncologist, not because they're trying to deceive the oncologist or trying to not disclose something to them, but they just didn't want to get an argument, let's say.
But, you know, we always recommend that you fully disclose everything you're doing, but that you also don't necessarily need to defend everything you're doing at the same time.
So, but for sure you want to fully disclose your supplements that you're taking and your doctor, remember, we're not treating you for your pregnancy, there may be certain things that you want to take for pregnancy too.
We have a very good organic whole food supplement that is a prenatal supplement that we just started carrying.
It's a great supplement, we used to carry ortho molecular prenatal and we switched to this one because it's a whole food prenatal and we private labeled it, I think it's just called our clear prenatal, I think.
That will give you some nutrition that you're not now, so think about that, if you're pregnant, you know some it's pregnant for other people that didn't ask this question, friends that are pregnant, you really want a good whole food prenatal, I just couldn't find one for years.
And so we carried the ortho molecular and now we found a PHP that we private labeled their product, so you can look at our website for that.
Are there any cases when a person should not use sec tea.
Well, sure, I mean, sec tea is an herbal tea, technically it's, you know, there's probably not a farm for most people to be taking it.
But yeah, if you're taking too many things, you know, that's not necessarily good, if we didn't recommend it, but you feel like God's leading you to take sec, well, then by all means do what you feel like God's leading you to do.
Are there contraindications to sec tea, no, not that I know of, maybe with pregnancy, that would be, I do, but I don't know of any other things, I don't think there's any contraindications with any other meds with sec tea.
Can you do a foot bath in a sauna on the same day?
Yes, I don't see any problem with that.
In the thought behind this, I think, is are you pulling out too many minerals? No, I don't think that's an issue. I think you could do a foot bath in a sauna to save me, I don't see a problem with that.
Okay, some questions that chat in there, another provider has recommended six curcumin IVs to aid fighting pancreatic cancer any comments on that. Well, if you do a Google search on curcumin cancer, you will literally find hundreds and hundreds of pages of articles, there's thousands of studies that have done and done on curcumin and cancer.
So just because maybe we didn't put you on it or we didn't test you on it, I don't think you can, I don't think you can do any harm with curcumin. There are some people that have a sensitivity to curcumin, curcumin is the act of ingredient turmeric, and some people can have a sensitivity to turmeric.
It's pretty rare, though, I mean, it's not that common. So I don't see any problem with that. If you feel like, Kim, that God's leading you to do that, you don't give it a try.
Curcumin is one of my favorite nutrients, something I take out a regular basis.
And it's so I don't see that there's really any harm in trying them.
Hippies chickpea puffs. Oh, yes, the chickpea puffs are good as well, talk because we talked about those paleo puffs for the person who likes cheetos.
That's another suggestion. The hippie is I H I P P E A S. That's how you pronounce it chickpea. I think that's the brand name chickpea puffs are good. They're vegan, they're organic and they have several flavors.
I don't know that you guys can see the chat. Can you guys see the chat. Can you chat. Yes or no. You can see the chat when we're doing this.
Yes, you can. Okay. Well, then you can see that. Next, I had a CBC panel done today because I'm feeling weak by Hebeglomer was down even lower 8.3.
So normally Hebeglomer should be around 13 to 16. I think I don't have all the normals memorized. And my red blood cell count was 2.7. That's pretty low. 8.3 is pretty low.
I finished up three iron infusions, hoping that would cure the anemia. What is going on and how could I resolve this good question.
I take redacted iron twice per day normally. It didn't while doing the iron infusions after discussing it with Anne. I'll go back to that.
But is that going to help my primary care physician thinks it's not from low iron, but it's from the cancer.
So again, you know, if you Google search different types of anemia, you're going to find all sorts of different causes of anemia.
The first thing that you should look at with a cause of anemia is their bleeding going on. You have blood bloody stools. Do you have black stools because you're bleeding higher up.
And it's being digested. The iron is being digested and broken down and it's discolored your stools to a dark color. No, don't have that is there bleeding anywhere else in your body. That's what we want to look for.
Number one cause of anemia is bleeding somewhere. Number two cause of anemia is okay. You have a comorbidity of cancer with your anemia to start looking at is the cancer gobbled up the iron.
That's what your primary care doctor is thinking that it's not just a normal low iron anemia. It's what's called what we refer to many times of the zoom calls as what it's called as an anemia of a chronic disease in this case cancer.
Yes, that's possible that iron can be be gobbled up by the cancer itself. So what is the treatment that for that? Well, it's still to use iron because you're balancing out whether, you know, okay, well, if I feed by body iron, I feed the cancer. Well, in a one sense, yes, but you can't, you know, get let your iron get so low.
You know, eating more beets eating foods that that will help build higher levels like that can be helpful, but you I don't know exactly you should talk to your primary care doctor. I don't know exactly what the iron infusions were if they were IVs with just iron in them or were they a blood fusion like getting packed red blood cells.
That's something different. So if you're getting packed red blood cells typically that's going to raise your hemoglobin up fairly quickly if it's if it's just iron IVs then maybe that's not going to be enough to raise that up. So again, talk to them about that.
That's that's something we do in the office. So it's really hard to make too many in depth comments. I don't love to make it if you're in comment about that. So, but certainly get it back on your supplemental iron, at least for sure that would be something I would consider.
Alright, okay, thank you for that comment whether I can see the chat in the live version, but not the recorded are good. Any other questions.
For those of you that have not had their genetic review yet, I know there are some people on here that are more in the relatively new stage of working with us. Remember that genetic review will be done.
Through that zoom call and you can see that on the member site under genetic review. So we have a page on the members only site for genetics. And that's where the zoom call is for them.
We do have a couple people out here that just started with us and haven't had their binder review yet. And so look at the binder section of the website of the members only site. And that's where they'll find the zoom call registration for the binder review.
So just a reminder for that any other questions.
How far apart can I have an MRI and PET scan and planning to have the both of these in September is it safe with the amount of radiation to have them close in days to each other.
Yeah, I don't I an MRI doesn't produce any radiation. So an MRI is a magnetic resident imaging. There's zero radiation with an MRI and PET scan is where you're going to have radiation. So you could actually have these things done on the same day if you want. So there's no issue there.
Can you recommend a dosage of turmeric that won't lower blood pressure.
Everybody's different. So some people do have a sensitivity to curcumin slash turmeric that does reduce blood pressure. Some people, like I said before, actually have IGG antibodies against turmeric and they end up with a sensitivity reaction.
So antibodies to a turmeric would be similar to have it antibodies to gluten or gliantic and gluten gliantic peptides. And you eat them and you can feel sick. You could have inflammation in your body elsewhere. So you can test for that. If you're concerned about that.
There is the best test for that is the Syrex array 10 the test for both IGG and IGM antibodies for about 300 different foods and it does test for turmeric.
Some people have a genetic predisposition where the turmeric does lower their blood pressure and that could be an advantage if they have high blood pressure.
Some people can take turmeric for high blood pressure. It does nothing to them.
So you just got to play with the dosage and be checking your blood pressure and see what it does.
I would suspect that if you took turmeric with food where you didn't get a spike in absorption, it would also help.
So if you take liposomal turmeric, you're going to get a better absorption. Just like if you take IV turmeric, you get instant absorption.
But if you take something with the food, you'll get slower absorption. And that can be good in a way sometimes as well. So I would be kind of looking at that when you take your dosage and your measure and your blood pressure.
You take using some sort of diary to make note of what what what you're eating with it.
Do you have a video or blog post out infrared sauna covering how long how hot, et cetera.
I don't know that I do, I don't remember making one, but I might have you'll have to search for it.
Typically though, I know I've answered this question in multiple zoom calls, but my typical answer for that is you start out slow. So if you're, if the,
if you just start new to sauna, I would say you start out slow and you go to tolerance.
Personally, when I started doing a sauna and I haven't done one for a while, but this winter, I'll start doing so does again.
You know, probably only now I'll probably only tolerate 15 minutes right away, but I first started I could tolerate about 10 minutes.
And then I worked up to, I think we got up to 25 minutes. So I just get I just get the ebgb's that I feel like I got to get out of there.
So everybody's a little bit different and everybody's a little bit different how much they sweat the whole purpose of the sauna is really to sweat you're really not going to raise core body temperature very much with the sauna you will get some and some benefit of that.
The main purpose in sauna is to, is to bypass your liver for detox pathways, your helping sweat.
And I do enough of that in the summer in my garden, so I don't feel like I need a sauna, but you're just taking some pressure off your liver and kidneys.
So you start out slow and typical temperatures 140 degrees.
But it's a good protein powder for cancer patients to use when we really only recommend the US enzymes slash faster supplement protein powder.
It comes in a chocolate or a vanilla and the reason is it's the one protein powder that's not high in glutamine.
So it's by US enzymes that comes in a bag. It's US enzymes I've said this before, all the supplement companies that we carry they aren't the most anal impurity.
They're like crazy anal impurity so they have a very good clean product.
That's really the only one that we sell is that one. I think we might carry a designs for health one.
I think they actually source their enzymes from US enzymes any so I would like to try sunflower seed powder or watermelon seed powder from Sprout Libby.
I'm not familiar with those. So I really can't comment on that.
Not familiar with this to avoid glutamates. I know we have to avoid bone broth.
By the same logic should we avoid any meats cooked for a long time like prop pot meals.
Well, you're going to it's not that you're going to not get glutamate in your diet.
But it's not the purpose is it to not get any glutamine in your diet. So understand glutamine and glutamate are not the same thing though glutamine does convert to glutamate and vice versa.
It's dependent upon a specific gene. However, that does happen even if you have the gene defects that affect if you have the gene defects you can convert glutamine to glutamates quicker.
And I don't get so technical but they function differently so glutamine is an amino acid.
So an amino acid is used by your body to build proteins also enzymes are proteins, but they actually function to cut apart proteins like a scissors.
And enzymes are built from amino acids too. Your body uses amino acids to build so many things you need amino acids. Therefore, you need protein. What is protein? Well, protein is a long chain amino acid. So like meat you eat a piece chicken.
It's a long chain amino acid where you start breaking it down by chewing it.
So some initial digestion goes into your mouth and you secrete an enzyme called battalion from your parodern glands that then help break down some carbohydrates and help break down some of the proteins proteins as they break down.
A long chain of amino acids think of like a pearl necklace and enzymes help break that down.
Think of that breakdown is using a scissors cutting that pearl necklace up into from a necklace of 400 beads now to necklace them 15 and 30 and 25 and 20 and 17.
Those are called peptides. So peptides are chains of amino acids that came from a longer chain protein.
And then you break those down into finally just two beads or one bead. One bead is an amino acid. So amino acids are one bead of a protein or one bead of a peptide.
Body is only supposed to absorb either an amino acid or a dye peptide meeting two beads together two amino acids tied together.
And anything larger that you shouldn't even be absorbing and problem is we have damaged gut walls and we absorb these larger peptides and that our body can make antibodies against them. We have all this immune issues and this is what has caused major autoimmune problems.
And it takes a lot of our energy from our immune system to deal with these things and that can be a contributor to cancer.
Glutinates actually function as a neurotransmitter in different parts of our body.
Most commonly we talk about glutamates in your brain. They're an excitatory neurotransmitter in your brain. Well, that could cause all sorts of things from anxiety to OCD.
Certainly anxiety and OCD that most common things you think of an ADD ADHD all are high glutamate issues.
So people with those conditions typically have a gene slip defect. Maybe they just eat a lot of glutamates. That's the bad thing about modusodium glutamate MSG in foods. Why does modusodium glutamate do?
It's a glutamate that goes right to your brain because it's a glutamate acts as a neurotransmitter, fires your brain. It gets it excites different neurons in your brain.
It actually makes you crave that food more. That's why they put modusodium glutamate in food because it fires the glutamate receptors in your brain. It makes you crave that food and you think all these cheetos are just crazy.
Great. I just love these cheetos. We eat more cheetos.
It sells more food. That's why they do it. But it's very damaging to our brains, very damaging. So glutamates are not good for us because it causes our neurons to literally burn out and can be a contributor to both brain cancers and to
neurodegenerative diseases. So we should be staying away from MSG's foods containing MSGs which are very high amount of the process foods these days and a lot of the foods that you can buy in restaurants.
Now, glutamate just from a good organic chicken will break down to glutamate as well. It can't get me wrong. We need glutamate. You need excitatory neurotransmitters. You need to have that. We just don't eat excess ones.
So it's a matter of having a balance. So if you're not, if your cancer isn't, isn't driven by glutamate and we've taken you off of meat, then no, you could have meat and I would say no, don't worry about cooking it.
You know, you know, you know, crock pot. I gave you a 15 minute answer on a question that if all I needed to say is no, don't worry about cooking in the crock pot. Sorry, I have a habit of doing that.
But, but glutamates are different. And yes, if we're, if we're just constantly eating meat for breakfast, lunch and dinner, we're just constant humongous carnivores. We could have access glutamates from that.
So we can have an hour long discussion, obviously, on glutamates, glutamates in the brain and what glutamates do as a neurotransmitter and then what glutamates can do to brain cancers and what glutamate can do to feed cancer because glutamate is very necessary for growth.
So, but no, long answer for really what you wanted, short answer, I wouldn't worry about using proc pots for cooking meat.
That's not what we're concerned about. That's not going to increase the amount of glutamate in the food that's not going to increase the amount of glutamates exposure, whether you ate that meat that you just cooked other stove for 10 minutes for whether you ate a crock pot.
If you're not increasing the amount of glutamates in the food, why did they say all that stuff? Sorry, don't you carry buggy spray anymore.
I don't see in your story. You see the do-it-yourself kit call the clinic. We do have some made. Yes, we do.
I don't know how many bottles we have made.
Well, if you haven't used that, it really works. It's it's you can make your own with essential oils. That's what it's using.
It really works well. So, call call the clinic and ask.
We, I know we haven't know why we wouldn't see it on the site, but I don't know.
Thank you. I appreciate it. I was not clear about that. Hopefully I cleared it up. I didn't just muddy the water. Apologize.
Okay. Is being very thirsty a result of taking betagene?
No, I don't think so. So, betagene is an oxaloacetate, which helps reduce glutamine in the brain tremendously.
So, I don't think that it would have any effect on first whatsoever, nor detoxification.
Again, you may have asked that question earlier. Maybe you were on yet.
This one my son just started his pro call and he has been so thirsty.
I, and my answer to that was make go make sure you go get a complete blood count glucose level and CBC to make sure his electrolytes are on a balance for some reason.
Or his glucose level is spiky or something like that. I would go get that checked.
I don't think anything can happen. I've never heard of betagene causing thirst.
And certainly if he has this big dietary change, this glucose can be bouncing up and down. That can cause thirst.
Yeah, I don't, I don't know. I would get it was me. I would, if you're like, this is crazy. He's just like super thirsty.
I would make sure you get a CBC and a complete, a complete blood count, which is the CBC and a metabolic panel.
And just and see if they can run some electrolyte panelists to make sure you could also get a finger prick glucose, a glucometer and target and test your glucose to make sure that isn't spiky as well.
And I've come, anybody can have comorbidities that he didn't know, maybe you were, he was very prediabetic before all this.
I don't know the history and details you, I would get that checked.
That's one of the things take up with severe thirst. You think of early diabetes, blood sugar, headly problems, simple to check. No, it's not complete.
It's better to get a hemoglobin A1C, but to get a just a blood glucose level would be helpful. Any other questions you bet.
So just remember if this recording works, sometimes the zoom recordings don't work, and it doesn't end up recording and gets lost with this.
If this works, we get it uploaded to YouTube, but it usually is under the numbers saying within about 10 to 15 minutes. So after we say goodbye, I do that.
So hopefully if you missed a question that you had sent in that I addressed a little bit earlier, you'll be able to listen to that.
Okay, so I think we will say goodbye if there's no other questions, we'll get this uploaded.
All right, thank you guys, we'll be praying for you.
And keep praying for us, appreciate it, we cherish your prayers.
All right, bye bye.